yeah I read a book actually this was
kind of for business but I really
thought it was great
it's called why do we care about
literary characters and it's by a
professor at Stanford called Blakey
Vermeil and it's an example of what
we're talking about earlier which is
trying to apply some of the discoveries
of experimental psychology and cognitive
science to novels in particular to ask
the question why is it that people care
very much about what happens to a
fictional character given that not only
have we never met this person but the
person doesn't exist but we actually we
see a movie or read a novel and bad guy
gets away with it we're pretty upset why
would why would we care so she has an
explanation from evolutionary psychology
and but she has some other insights as
well and to what it means to read and
what it means to identify with
characters that have to do with the way
we relate to other people and even
though I felt the cognitive science part
of it I could take her leave I thought
that her manner of reading novels was
great it's a wonderful book and she just
has a great voice as a critic and I felt
I would follow her wherever she led
sure of course yeah most of them hans
cos start probably the magic here of the
Magic Mountain when I was a kid I read
that I mean not a kid probably about 20
and I remember being like deeply
invested in that character I don't even
know why anymore but I remember feeling
I really mattered to me how things came
out for him ya know that's part of why I
suppose I suppose everybody does get
attached to characters whether movies
are stories but I think that that's part
of the reason you get involved with
literature is because there's something
that grabs you about it and then you
want to figure out why that's part of
what the job is really is to figure out
what what is it about this story or this
character this outcome or the style or
this voice that that gets to you what is
what's getting to you does it mean and
that's really an interesting problem to
trying to figure out so that's what this
book was give taking a stab at doing and
I just thought it was a pretty original
and fresh and fun take on the subject